la cgt des yvelines a accueilli une
formation organisée par l'institut de
recherche de la confédération européenne
des syndicats
que ce soit le ms os hongrois logib et
autrichiens ou le fg bt belge plusieurs
syndicats de pays européens représentés
avec la volonté de lutter contre
l'extrême droite
une des pistes que nous avons dégagé
pendant cette formation
c'est une déception des personnes vivant
en europe des citoyens européens aussi
bien que des personnes vivant en europe
par rapport aux perspectives futures
réflexion sur les arguments partage des
expériences face au parti nationaliste
chacun est revenu sur sa situation dans
son pays l'a évité en allemagne l'italie
avec le ministre de l'intérieur matteo
salvini ou encore le premier ministre
hongrois viktor orban
bref tout comme face au tfc je dois
avouer que l'afd est vraiment un
challenge seulement pour la société
allemande mais aussi pour les syndicats
union facing nous faisons face
maintenant je veux dire sur le long
terme de ces mecs dans la fabrication
des politiques publiques et sur l'
influence de l'agenda politique de
l'allemagne d'essence à devenir présente
une partie de l'idéologie qui contraste
avec les syndicats union des contrastes
mixer avec nos missions d'une
présentation des travaux world of life
freedom moins de liberté il n'y a plus
de dialogue social
le premier ministre viktor orban a
ouvert le chemin vers le tripartisme
avec les structures de dialogue social
sochaux nous avons les structures la
seconde session de formation se tiendra
du 3 au 5 avril 2019 à budapest avec la
volonté de peser lors de la campagne des
élections européennes